gratidão pelo trabalho que a senhora
realizante gratidão imensa graça possa
achar pasta
boa noite a todos
eu estou aqui pra falar então da casa de
apoio com a líbia no dia 28 de julho
desculpe se a minha emoção travar a
minha conversa 28 de julho de 2001
eu perdi uma filha com um câncer no
cérebro
essa filha deixou três filhos
ei foi muito difícil é um sentimento
devastador que eu acredito que o nosso
irmão ali tenha conhecimento disso
porque investe o processo natural da
nossa vida
até os pais é natural perder uma filha é
antinatural
aí eu passei
vivendo o luto aquilo que chama de luta
né que a forma de você tentar superar a
rotina a saudade e tudo que vem
nessa perto mas eu tinha muita
curiosidade de saber das outras mais
como ela estava administrando essas
perdas
passado um ano quase dois anos
eu estava na rua caminhando e nesse
momento eu digo muito que foi uma luz
eu encontrei uma senhora conhecida e
disse a ela sabia que ela tinha perdido
um filho também e disse a ela eu estou
com vontade de fazer na minha casa
uma reunião das mães que perderam os
filhos ela imediatamente acatou e eu
disse a ela então vou pedir a você que
convide as pessoas do teu conhecimento e
eu os convidarei as que eu conheço
e assim no dia 23 de maio de 2003
eu reuni na minha casa aqui na nereu
ramos no edifício 12 mães dessas 12 6
tinham perdido filho por câncer
as demais de outras formas eu confesso a
vocês que foi uma reunião onde eu me
coloquei com o observador a pra ver
todas aquelas mães seus sentimentos
muitos levaram fotos outras mensagens e
assim nós ficamos chocando né as nossas
experiências e os nossos sentimentos
estava sentada do meu lado
uma senhora também conhecida naquela
época não tinha muita intimidade e
estávamos conversando e trocando
experiências conversas né e está nas
nossas filhas o que elas diziam durante
o tratamento
qual o objetivo delas qual era o sonho e
ela então me falava que a filha dizia
que se obtivesse a cura
gostaria de trabalhar junto às pessoas
sofrendo
eu sempre digo que eu fui teve uma
inspiração porque eu não convidei
aquelas pessoas minha casa para dizer
vamos fazer uma casa para câncer
não eu não tinha dentro de mim é isso
aquilo
surgiu e eu disse pra ela vamos fazer
uma casa pra câncer ela disse vamos e
foi nesse momento que participamos as
outras
e neste dia estava também nessa reunião
uma jovem senhora amiga muito é muito
amiga da minha filha que fez questão de
em gás a reunião quando sobe assim que
terminou a reunião
ela me disse dona neuzi senhora quiser
procurar essa casa eu vou com a senhora
eu tenho um temperamento assim de quando
eu tenho objetivo é bem diferente
me chamo de teimosa e eu prefiro dizer
que eu sou perseverante
e no dia seguinte fomos então em busca
de uma casa
nós não sabíamos nem como procurar mas
saímos perguntando e tal
e aquele dia nós não tivemos muito
sucesso mas no dia seguinte um conhecido
uma pessoa amiga me mandou um recado
dizendo que na rua presidente roosevelt
tinha uma casa para alugar
nós imediatamente fomos lá era uma
casinha pequena amarelinha e nós
passamos a chamar da casinha amarelinha
é entramos em contato com a proprietária
ela imediatamente né acedeu é o nosso
pedido e nós então a jogamos essa casa
era uma casa pequenininha tinha um
pequeno entrada dois quartos e uma copa
cozinha pequeno banheiro mas nós já
estamos satisfeitos que só tínhamos
encontrado alguma coisa e aí para
mobiliar como é que nós vamos fazer
eu sou lageana tenho bastante amigo sou
espírita tem um grupo também espírita e
todo esse grupo se uniu a gente então
rapidamente uma trouxe cama colchão
outra roupa de cama pratos enfim uma
semana
nós tínhamos condições de receber alguém
mas como é que nós vamos receber as
pessoas na porta sem canceroso como é
que aí resolvemos ir até o hospital
tereza ramos no serviço de quimioterapia
que era conduzido pela doutora evando e
fomos colocará ela nossa nosso projeto
a doutora ivana sempre é auxiliou muito
as pessoas porque essas criaturas que
vinham de fora é fazer a quimioterapia
ela terminar seu tratamento é um
tratamento de três quatro cinco seis
horas onde a pessoa fica recebendo soro
e elas vêm nas kombis nos nós vans da
secretaria eles trazem depois em buscar
mas nesse meio tempo
elas ficam sentadinhos num banco de
madeira na parte de fora do hospital e
ali muitas vezes a doutora e vanda dava
alguma coisa pra comprar um lanche
imaginem vocês quem tem essa experiência
sabe comum é difícil tudo isso pois bem
a doutora e vanda nos deu total apoio e
nós fizemos uma parceria em toda a
pessoa que fosse entrar na nossa casa
seria através do hospital traria de lá
sua ficha e assim nós começamos eu
sempre digo que um fato me tocou
extremamente foi que a primeira pessoa
que chegou nessa casa
paciente o nome dela era lips e ela veio
com uma filha ea filha se apresentou
meu nome é maduro é o nome da minha
filha
aí nesse momento pensei ok está me dando
a mensagem negócio por aí
em seguida nós então ficamos recebendo
atendendo essas pessoas outras pessoas
que gostado da ideia e do trabalho foram
se juntando a nós em um espaço de seis
meses
nós não tínhamos mais espaço porque essa
casinha tinha só dois quartos e nós
acomodavam os quatro camas
passados seis meses nós tínhamos que
mudar
e nessa mesma rua presidente roosevelt
tinha uma outra casa da mesma
proprietária
veja como são as coisas que fomos
conversar com ela nos alugou já era uma
casa maior e uma sala grande uma cozinha
grande também aí tínhamos quatro quartos
conseguimos colocar 12 camas nosso
trabalho contínuo mas a nossa vontade o
nosso desejo era de ter uma sede própria
algo próprio pros doentes porque ali era
uma casa que nos servia uma churrascada
muito íngreme
e só um banheiro mas estava servindo
para o nosso propósito
um belo dia e neste momento nós já
estávamos assim tentando iniciar um
trabalho artesanal para poder ajudar a
casa porque aí tem um detalhe importante
tudo isso que foi pensado e
imediatamente criado foi que nós vamos
pagar o aluguel
quem vai pagar o aluguel uma pessoa da
comunidade o senhor sabendo do nosso
objetivo nosso trabalho foi ter connosco
e nos disse eu pago dois anos do aluguel
dessa casa
foi uma coisa maravilhosa para nós a que
nós ea seguir o trabalho com mais
tranquilidade
nós já nos reunimos e ali nós iniciamos
os trabalhos
um belo dia nós estamos unidos e foi nos
fazer uma visita
a doutora vi uma carreira a primeira
médica de lages é uma pessoa que vive a
parte social solidária sempre
trabalhando com a comunidade e ela
chegou lá fazendo a visita ele lá depois
as nossas orações ela disse neusa tenho
uma coisa pra te dar
eu vim te dar é doar pra vocês um
terreno pra vocês só será sede de vocês
vocês não imaginam a nossa alegria nossa
felicidade de receber porque nós
queríamos a gente sempre imaginava o
terreno mas não queríamos pedir para a
municipalidade porque sabíamos que nós
iríamos lá nos bairros mais distantes
nós queríamos um terreno próximo à
matéria o hospital é que os pacientes
pudesse ir a pé não necessitasse de
transporte quando ela nos disse isso
ficamos felizes porque esse terreno fica
muito próximo ao hospital que hoje
atende os pacientes
e daí onde é que nos vão tirar dinheiro
fazer uma construção
a comunidade estava nos ajudando com
doações para a gente poder sustentar
porque todo paciente que entra nossa
casa não tem qualquer custo sai tudo do
nosso trabalho nós passado também algum
tempo a gente sempre batalhando
procurando dessa altura toda nós já
tínhamos preparado toda a documentação
os registros já estávamos documentada
como entidade
e aí a dia uma suma lageana enfermeira
estava na frente da da secretaria de
saúde do estado
e ela veio a lages para comemorar sete
anos dó da partida da quimioterapia
quando ela sobre o nosso trabalho elas
nos chamou e nos disse assim neusa
procurem fazer um projeto toda a
documentação sexto terry porque a verba
eu consigo para vocês
imediatamente nós procuramos a meu
marido arquiteto fez a o projeto da casa
e conseguimos na fazer então essa esse
contrato com a emi a secretaria de saúde
e fizemos o primeiro piso
fizemos o primeiro piso mais um andar
com 24 25 leitos
a aí já foi feito pra que pudéssemos
estar dentro de todas as normas de
vigilância de tudo fizemos uma cozinha
industrial e tudo aquilo que era exigido
aí nós tínhamos 25 leitos já conseguimos
não conseguíamos acolher 25 pessoas mas
nós precisamos sustentar essas pessoas
nós precisamos dar a elas o máximo de
conforto
então nós começamos a fazer projetos
para poder conseguir um mobiliário para
essa casa
você sabe quem lida quantidade que a
gente faz projetos com toda a
documentação
mandamos né pros das organizações
responsáveis e conseguimos então
mobilizar toda a casa
recebíamos inicialmente não 25 pacientes
porque nós tínhamos só a quimioterapia
ea quimioterapia é não faz com que as
pessoas fiquem por exemplo um mês todo
ela fazia o seu tratamento de 34 dias
voltava pessoas suas casas hoje uma das
das a diretoria até disse aqui que nós
queremos uma casa tão grande assim se
nós não temos pacientes gente deus está
conosco
a radioterapia vai chegar e não de moda
é exatamente a partir da radioterapia a
nossa casa lotou infelizmente hoje nós
temos uma lista de espera para entrar na
casa
aí começamos a sentir a casa estava
pequena porque era muito grande a
demanda
novamente buscamos aí nós tínhamos no
governo um lageano nós fomos novamente o
encontro pedir né pra que nos dessem uma
verba para construir daí o segundo o
terceiro piso
graças a deus conseguimos o terceiro
piso aí com 10 leitos a mais e fizemos
sim vez de todo andar há quartos nós
fizemos um espaço de 70 metros quadrados
para lazer desses pacientes porque antes
eles permaneciam então na no hall de
entrada a porta que teria tem que ficar
aberta e eu me incomodava muito com
aquela situação de frio nosso clima é
muito frio e eles ficavam ali então
conversando é fazendo seu lazer
o hoje eles têm um espaço muito grande
para fazer outro andar foi feito a casa
está lá pronta graças a deus a nós nesse
meio tempo recebemos da pró vida um
carrinho um carro pequeno mas que nos
dava a condição de levar aquelas
criaturas que não tinham condições de
caminhar nem de pagar um táxi a levar
por seu tratamento foram foi outra
bênção de deus
aí nós então precisávamos do espaço para
continuar os nossos trabalhos o nosso
artesanato que é o que me mantém hoje em
dia a nossa casa
nesse meio tempo nós fomos agraciados
também com a verba é é para que nós
pudéssemos fazer comprar o terreno e
fazer hoje nós temos uma oficina onde
nós trabalhamos na nós fazemos os
cobertores e soft
nós temos dois eventos no ano primeiro
evento é o jantar dançante onde nós
colocamos todos esses cobertores para
venda e no segundo semestre nós fazemos
um grande bazar na bb na expondo todo o
nosso artesanato
isso aí nos dá condição na de nós
continuarmos também esse trabalho é e
temos um testemunho muito importante dos
médicos da radioterapia e eles nos dizem
que os pacientes que ficam na nossa casa
e isso eu digo com muita humildade tem
outro resposta do seu tratamento porque
lá eles têm uma cama confortável
eles têm cinco refeições por dia eles
têm uma área de lazer e eles têm a
liberdade de ir e vir
isso para nós é muito muito nos traz
muita paz muita alegria
eu pessoalmente
quero dizer a vocês que a perda da minha
filha continue vendendo a saudade
continua mas a paz voltou no meu coração
e eu sempre digo que a perda o problema
aaaah não é brutalizar uma pessoa
o sofrimento não é brutalizar é o
despertar é você despertar para o outro
para o bem estar do outro é ver o outro
porque durante o tratamento da minha
filha fiquei cinco meses em do hospital
ali houve muito sofrimento muita
necessidade e isso foi uma das coisas
que me tocou muito então hoje eu digo
pra vocês
a saudade é grande mas a paz é maior
ainda e eu sempre quis encerrar diria
vocês assim uma frase de francisco de
assis é dando que se recebe
e eu recebi a paz obrigado a todos vocês